welcome to gamespot of Thrones you are
watching it just a mere clip from a much
longer show where myself Kate and Dave
talk about Game of Thrones like the
massive nerds that we are so make sure
to come join us at youtube.com slash
gamespot or at gamespot com or on iTunes
hopefully we'll see you there it might
finally be time for one of the biggest
game of thrones fan theories to be
confirmed cage one take this one yes
lightly as he says it's the most
exciting it's our plus l equals J the
theory that Rhaegar and Lyanna had a
baby it was Jon Snow and Ned adopted him
and pretended he was just some bastard
that he done did we see Brown looking
into Ned Stark's past in this episode
and we also see that it's going to
happen in next episode so in this
episode you see Ned at Winterfell
training with his brother Benjen and you
see Liana for the first time which is
very exciting because we know that means
she's gonna be a part of these little
green seeing trips that he's having so
next week we see that Ned is standing
outside some kind of tower fighting some
guards could it be the Tower of joy well
they are Targaryen guards and that guy
yep I'm gonna shout out to that guy for
his Ned Stark accent and impression
because it is a lot on and now begins
now attends so for non book readers like
myself what is the territory so the
Tower of joy is a tower built
specifically by raiga for Liana he keeps
her in there because he doesn't want
anyone to touch her so during Robert's
rebellion she is up in that Tower doing
god knows what and when Ned actually
enters her room she's there in a bed of
blood as its described in the books and
she dies in his arms with the words
promise me Ned on her lips and we know
that he sees winter roses blue roses
those are kind of Leon a symbol those of
what Rhaegar gives her when he crowns so
the queen of love and beauty so it's all
very symbolic but the r plus l equals J
theory states that Liana's bed of blood
is actually a child bed having just
given birth to Reagan's baby
ie Jon Snow mm-hmm so this might finally
be the moment when we find out what went
on in that Tower whether Liana actually
had a baby what she died of exactly and
whether John is actually the blood of
the Dragon and there's a little
interesting side theory might not be
entirely true and I'm not anywhere near
as invested in this one but me reread is
currently a company brand in the north
and she's very bored as we see in this
episode now Mira's father is Howland
Reed who is currently m.i.a but he is
the only surviving person that was at
the Tower of joy that day so there are
theories as to whether Mara knows the
tale her dad told her the tail and
she'll somehow be key in helping brian
understand what went on or even more
interestingly mirror is another R + L
baby the twin sister of john and they
split the twin babies up gave one to Ned
want to Howland they went off grew up
look kind of similar in that they both
have dark curly hair and you know I
don't think that's that's probably not
true because yeah so what but there's
another theory for you Kenny seems to me
that people have been like sort of half
ignoring mirror this whole time yeah so
I'm less convinced about that pub I
think that the heard dad being there
were definitely yes have repercussion
cuz i think this episode they're
definitely seeding the fact that she's
like oh well i'm here but there's no
point in me being here and the girls
like no you know you must be there for
bran I mean I was good